everyone welcome back today I'm gonna
give you another guitar tip and today's
tip is all about sitting
[Music]
I'm always surprised that I can go to
concerts with incredibly virtuosic
musicians who are sitting in such a
contorted way that is really doing them
a disservice and even them even this
amazing performer that we can worship
over can improve could improve their
playing if they simply sat better
[Music]
the first reason we need to sit well is
so that we can breathe properly if one
has bad slouched posture the first thing
that goes is our ability to breathe
freely and if we're not breathing well
we're not playing well once we stop
breathing well our muscles tighten and
it's a chain reaction which just can
only damage our plane so let's go over
some quick tips on how you can sit
better whether you're at home practicing
or whether you're in the middle of a
concert okay so if our goal is to sit
well with an instrument we have to first
learn how to sit well without one a
basic rule that I always tell myself a
sort of mantra that you can take home
with you is head over heart heart over
hips so maybe from this angle it's
better to see if I'm slouching my head's
in front of my heart right and my heart
is in front of my hips so I can correct
this by head over heart heart over hips
and if those things aren't in line we
are not stable
we are not supported and our muscles
small muscle groups are working extra
hard to support our skeleton and instead
if we simply follow the mantra head over
heart heart over hips everything falls
into place and we can relax into this
nice supported posture which means our
muscles can work more efficiently which
means we are better performers
a really important thing to consider is
the type of chair you're using so very
often I show up to a gig and the chair
they're providing me is awful it either
has arms or it's too high too low at
home I'm just using a very simple sort
of dining chair with a cushion and it's
very important that we find the right
height of chair or use a chair that's
adjustable like a piano bench because if
our chairs too high are our legs can be
at too much of an angle and even worse
we could be tiptoeing on the ground
which causes a lot of tension through
the legs and the thing about tension is
that it translates and works its way up
and before you know it tension in your
foot can lead to tension in your fingers
if the chairs too low your knees are too
high it encourages slouching and you
can't breathe another bad chain reaction
[Music]
okay now that we're sitting well we can
add an instrument there are a number of
support devices on the market for
holding the guitar if you are just a
acoustic guitar player playing folk pop
rock something like that feel free to
simply put the guitar on the right the
right thigh in the curved section here
and leave the guitar parallel to the
ground and this is a this is a fine
playing position especially if you're
playing mostly chords in first position
it's okay just be careful it can really
encourage this sort of sitting position
so head of our heart harbor hips and you
got it another idea if you're not going
to use a guitar support is to cross the
right leg over the left leg this takes
some getting used to because for some
people who haven't done this your leg
can fall asleep but you can reposition
it and eventually you'll learn to sit in
this position for very long periods of
time flamenco guitar players for example
mostly sit like this and they can do it
for hours on end one thing I love about
crossing my leg is it brings the guitar
up a little higher which makes it easier
to play and if you sit back in the chair
it encourages a long lengthy spine and
I'm very comfortable so when I'm
teaching or just kind of hanging out and
improvising I often sit like this now if
you're a classical guitarist you're
probably going to want to hold the
guitar at more of a 45 degree angle
which gives you greater access to the
upper frets which is definitely needed
for the repertoire so the traditional
way is to use a footstool to bring the
guitar in that higher position and so by
putting the footstool on the left foot
it raises it up we put the curve of the
guitar on the left leg and the guitar
drops between our legs giving us this 45
degree angle
now I don't like the footstool
personally I have a long torso and so
for me to use a footstool I have to
raise the my knee super high to get the
guitar in a good spot so depending on
your proportions it might work great
or you might like me need to search for
a different type of device my favorite
type of guitar support is this guy it's
called an ER go play and it uses suction
cups which go onto the side of the
guitar doesn't hurt the instrument and
it really allows you to customize all of
sorts of angles that are required to get
the guitar exactly where you want it so
for me this is incredibly comfortable
you can adjust the guitar this way that
way higher or lower and the tilt which
is very important now here are some
recommendations for general rules about
how to hold the classical guitar I think
something approximating the 45 degree
angle is great although of course some
people prefer a bit more tilt some
people prefer a bit less I don't think
this is an option for classical
guitarists and so certainly not
something along this height now then
there's this angle to consider the the
tilt of the guitar I think having the
guitar vertical is less than ideal
instead I think if you let the guitar
dip back a bit against the chest it
rests directly on my sternum actually
kind of in the middle of my chest about
there and the extra bit of tilt makes it
easier for the right hand to get to the
strings and allows you to really feel
the weight of the arm on the left hand
another thing I often see is guitarists
who have one leg sticking out straight
or the the foots on the side and I would
greatly encourage you to keep both feet
flat on the ground for stability and so
that everything is in line and you can
really let go of your muscles and still
stay supported I think this allows for
the most efficient playing possible
now another thing I see often is people
trying to sort of look over the neck of
the guitar they try to get their head
here to see the front of the fretboard
and it it results in a sort of turtle
thing and you can hear my voice when I'm
when I'm speaking here and then I move
my head out here I sort of lose lose my
voice a bit and can't breathe so don't
do this it's not necessary and it's not
even helping you people think that if
they can see the front of the fretboard
that their fingers will be more accurate
but actually on the guitar with training
we don't need to see the front of the
strings we need to feel them and our
muscle memory will tell us where to land
the only thing I can really see when I'm
sitting well is I could see the top
string here and maybe the underside of
the fifth and fourth string otherwise I
can't actually see the first three
strings if you can I think that means
your guitar is too tilted or it means
you're doing the turtle thing so instead
of doing this whole turtle looking at
the guitar thing I want to encourage you
to use your eyes and some very nice free
movement from the head without moving it
in front of your body so for example if
I want to look at the the first fret I
can rotate my head to the left
tuck my chin just a little bit and then
with my eyes I can see the first fret
just fine okay so the last part of
today's tip is going to be about sitting
well even while under pressure like in a
performance setting so when we perform
we often get an adrenaline rush and it's
very common to tense our shoulders and
stop breathing so I'd encourage you
before you perform to take 10 long
breaths and to feel the the breath
coming from the belly and to pay
attention to that
swelling of the chest in the
decompression that'll help you relax a
bit and then once you're sitting well
doing the whole head of our heart heart
of her hips thing it's helpful to do two
things first is to roll your shoulders
back and let them relax the second is to
pay attention to your lower back muscles
and let those sort of let go for me
another thing that really helps us to
remember to relax the jaw so I like to
play often with my mouth slightly open
because it prevents me from clenching
and clenching the jaw shrugging the
shoulders all those stiff muscles do so
much damage to the the great technique
which you've spent countless hours
crafting so remember when performing to
breathe relax the jaw shoulders and let
those lower back muscles go alright guys
I hope you found that helpful
there will be more guitar tips coming so
stay tuned for more and if you haven't
subscribed to my youtube channel yet
please do you can see lots of new videos
coming out regularly on fiora buh lute
classical guitar and more see you later
[Music]
you